uh i always like trying to ask something
that's not to do with the movie at the
beginning
when did you both feel like you made it
as actors where you could like do this
for a living and not pay
and be able to pay rent
oh gosh recently
that's just that's such a great question
um
gosh i think for me it was it was sort
of hitting around about the
10-year mark when i realized i'd gone
that long without
having to do another job in order to
make a living i thought
maybe this is actually possible because
you know
elizabeth is joking but you never really
lose that
it could all be over tomorrow maybe
you're not joking elizabeth
but uh but yeah yeah about 10 years in
elizabeth oh well
i guess i'm about 10 years in so maybe
i'm
literally we've hit the marker but i all
i can remember very clearly the first
time i you know
someone gave me money to do acting and i
just thought it was so
so strange and you know like you get the
paycheck and you're like oh yeah this is
someone's gonna pay me for this like
it's utterly bizarre but i do remember
what i did with it which was
that i did pay my rent and i bought a
computer which was like
such a big deal because i didn't have
any tech i was like
i was like running to meetings in new
york with like post-it note like
directions and
you know so that's amazing um what do
you think
might surprise people to learn about the
making of an animated movie
or being part of peter rabbit well for
me the
the the surprising thing was just how
silly you feel
playing with these maquettes that
eventually are going to become
rabbits the like of which elizabeth
voices in the film
i dunno and rose had obviously done the
first film
and they had got past all of the
feelings of silliness this is my first
peter rabbit film and oh my goodness
doing that with an inanimate object
thinking your career is going to end
after people see this was very much my
friend
during the making of this film but it
was the fact that both donald rose
and will gluck our wonderful director
was so confident about it that's the
only thing that kept
me able to not uh you know get lost in a
feeling of self-loathing is that your
character's intention through most of
the scenes just thinking about
you're right okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
please don't let this be the end
[Laughter]
elizabeth i think for me little fun
little fun
side fact would be that you know rabbits
eat a lot
it took us a long time to figure out
what food
sounds most like rabbit eating food
while you're speaking lines over it i
think in the end we settled
we did actually settle for carrots uh
ironically
um and i remember because you know we
tried everything like
crisps and like you know we went like
high crunch low crunch
like high density low debt you know we
were trying to
it's a science and and then um
and then one day i remember being in the
studio and and will was like
it's not working we you know we have to
and someone goes wait
i there are vegetables around here and
someone brought this like
perfectly like vacuum sealed pack of
tiny baby carrots not as a joke though
they were just i'll never forget that so
that
is definitely in the film i have an
individual question for each of you guys
um elizabeth are you aware there is a
meme that's around
of nolan holding you with a gun are you
aware of this meme
oh my god you need to find this what
texts are they using it
for all things it's just a very funny
image i'll just say it like that
so you should look for it uh and david
if i'm not mistaken
uh it was your your children that
basically got you
to do this movie um what what
was it like literally they're like we're
done with you if you don't do this
well it was specifically my daughter my
nine-year-old daughter zoe
who had been completely besotted
with the first film and um
i had been approached about it but i was
about to go and direct
my first film this film the waterman and
you know that's no small feat your
directorial debut and i just felt
like i couldn't squeeze in peter rabbit
two and
be prepared enough for that so i turned
it down a couple of times but the third
time
i was at home will gluck is a very
persuasive man
and i was at home talking to my agent
and saying guys i just i just cannot do
this i don't want to mess up my
directorial debut and my daughter was in
the background and she heard the words i
cannot do this
and peter rabbit together and she went
dad
are you saying no to peter rabbit
i said i said zoey i i'm i'm directing
it you cannot
you cannot say no to peter rabbit dad
you have got to do it dad please do
peter rap
and so i i literally had to call my
agents back and say
i don't know i think i'll lose my
daughter if i don't
do this so um she is largely to blame
for me doing peter rabbit
that note i gotta go uh congrats and i
hope it's a huge hit for you guys
look up that meme for sure i'm gonna i'm
gonna look up at me
right now